the booster rail light is going
fantastically well so thank you so much
to everybody that who's come forward we
had 214 000 people just come over the
christmas weekend and we've done 32.4
million people so far so thank you to
all the volunteers the army obviously
our brilliant nhs staff and most of all
for everybody who's come forward
that's great news but in the meantime
hospitalizations in london are up 70 in
the past seven days now given these
concerning numbers isn't it too risky to
live things as they are without
introducing further restrictions ahead
of new year's eve well clearly that's
been a big question that's the one that
we've spent um every day a number of
times a day looking at the data so that
we could inform those decisions and yes
there are you know increase in the
number of cases many of those people
going into hospital are actually going
in with covid so they they actually get
tested on the way in but we do watch
very carefully all of the data um and we
have had some some good news that it
does seem to be a bit milder in terms of
severity but we do watch the
hospitalizations and we do watch the
number of people in hospitals all the
time
but so what exactly is the government's
advice on new year celebrations should
people exercise caution or should they
just go out and have big blowout parties
ahead of you know possible restrictions
in the new year well we've always said
um act cautiously since this new variant
uh came amongst us and it is highly
infectious many people will know
somebody who's had um who've caught this
over over this over the christmas period
so do be cautious take a lateral flow
test before you go out go to
well-ventilated areas um i've been to a
couple of outdoor parties actually
people have moved things to to to
outside so just be cautious um but you
know do try to enjoy yourself as well
but cautiously so if you're urging
people to be cautious that means that
less fewer people will be going to
restaurants and pubs
and these businesses are obviously
struggling at the moment because of that
they need more support in that case
don't they well that's why we put
package of measures of one billion pound
package of measures in place uh just
before this period uh but i've been out
a couple of times my sister's over from
the state so we have been out to a
couple of restaurants and they've been
pretty full um so you know i'm obviously
in london at the moment but i think
people are still going out but they're
just taking a lateral flow test before
and obviously being a bit more cautious
in the meantime other nations have
already introduced further measures
other nations um
scotland and northern ireland and wales
and some some mps are saying that they
are being too cautious what's your view
on that
well they have taken a different
approach before if you remember on the
19th of july when we uh unlocked all of
our country there was a a slightly
different approach taken in the devolved
nations we were looking at the data and
we wouldn't hesitate to act if we saw
that the data told us that we needed to
introduce further measures but so far
that's not what the data is telling us
and um
in the u.s isolation periods is being
cut out to five days to curb the effect
of omicron on businesses and you know to
not stop the functioning of society um
is that something that we should
consider over here well we did consider
that which is why we we very recently
went from ten days to seven days so
today if you test negative on day six
and day seven then your isolation period
will end so that's what we've done for
now and of course we'll await if if jcvi
want to give us further advice on that
then we'll uh will await their advice